in part one of this Nightwing training
video we discussed a leg training day
that Dick Grayson might use in order to
build more explosiveness whether it's
for running faster jumping higher
kicking harder or whatever else we
looked at using body weight moves we
looked at using compound lifts
plyometric jumping type training
one-legged training but when you think
of Nightwing you think of gymnastic
strength and when you think of gymnastic
strength you probably think about things
like the Iron Cross or the Maltese or
the planche and so in this video we're
gonna discuss a push day and a pull day
we're gonna look at how night we might
Train his upper body in order to develop
the kind of agility and power you need
to be able to punch harder climb over
things perform parkour swing over beams
and just move around your opponent's
with ease and then the next part we're
gonna bring it all together with a core
training day and mobility work so
without further ado let's get stuck into
the push-pull day for the Nightwing
training program
so of course if we're going to train our
upper body strength just like Nightwing
then we want to start using calisthenics
and gymnastic smooth Nightwing is an
elite level gymnast the siz how he
trains we see it in the cartoons the
comics the TV shows and so that's
obviously what we're going to emulate
bodyweight training in calisthenics can
be used like any other form of
resistance training you can combine it
with a weightlifting program for
instance in order to encourage
hypertrophy and general strength you can
use simple moves like the press up the
pull-up then use these in drop sets and
mechanical drop sets in order to
stimulate growth however that's not
what's really interesting about
gymnastic strength training there's a
few aspects of this kind of training
that tap into types of strength that are
missing from other forms of training in
particular the first one I want to focus
on is straight arm strength as the name
suggests this is the ability to exert
force with straight arms and that means
the ability to pull off moves like the
plants like the Maltese like the front
lever where your arms are straight
holding on to a bar or the ground then
you move your body around that if you
haven't trained for straight arm
strength before you're going to find
this remarkably difficult once you have
developed this kind of strength there
you'll find it really does transfer into
all kinds of other forms of training in
fact many people who've managed to
achieve the planche find that it also
massively improves their benchpress
apparently some people who've never done
a benchpress before but I've managed to
pull off planche will then be able to
benchpress twice their bodyweight simply
because they developed such power and
stability in those muscles before you
begin with this kind of training though
it's really important that you first
build up a basic level of strength and
particularly in your tendons tendons get
a lower blood supply than muscle
therefore they respond less quickly to
training and they're more likely to get
injured if you push them too hard if
your muscle runs ahead of your tendons
then you're looking at trouble studies
suggest that muscles will respond to
training in as little as eight days
whereas it can take up to two months for
your tendons to do the same thing
tenants also take longer to recover from
workouts but the good news is that you
keep tenzin strength for longer then you
keep muscle strength you perform a
straight I'll move all of that pressure
is going through the bicep which is
elongated and through the tendons this
builds massive biceps that's why Jim
Nast's have such big biceps but it's
also really strenuous on the tendons
that's why it's so important that you've
build
and build that basic level of resilience
first especially if you're new to this
kind of training you're also gonna want
to work on your shoulder mobility but
we'll talk about that more in the next
part of this series so for this reason
before you begin those advanced level
straight arm moves you should first just
build up that basic tolerance and
strength in the tendons you can do this
with a number of different moves for
instance you can use rings turned out
push-ups that means using gymnastics
rings with your palms facing forwards
separated and perform push-ups that way
likewise you can do it by using the
perfect pushup which twists the arm as
you go up and down using pseudo planche
push-ups you can find illustrations of
all this online very easily or by using
the super nated support hold on the
Rings or you just literally hold
yourself in an upright position with
straight arms again palms facing
forwards on gymnastics rings this is
harder than it looks
practice with that train lightly in
calisthenics for about two months and
then you could begin to start adding in
those progressions and from there that's
how you start to build up that strength
you need for those isometric holds so
you might start with a crow pose just
balancing on your hands with your knees
tucked up by your elbows then you might
move on to the crane pose then the tuck
planche then the one-legged tuck planche
and the straddle plant where your legs
are wide apart thereby spreading the
weight and bringing your center of
gravity closer to the point of contact
and then the full planche which is
obviously what we're going for
so isometric holds unless you add a
press so you're gonna try and build up
to about a minute of hold before you
then begin to incorporate the next level
up with movements like handstand presses
for instance or perhaps like typewriter
pull-ups you might attempt to do a
certain number of repetitions before you
then add in the next progression up you
can then still keep using that easier
progression as part of your training but
just begin those sessions with the
hardest version of that move the
Russians generally get harder and harder
and they do this in many different ways
either by isolating one muscle group so
that one muscle is taking more of the
weight or by lengthening the lever arm
thereby moving the center of gravity
away from you essentially meaning you
have to apply more pressure this is how
we kind of fake increasing the amount of
weight that we're using and the easiest
way to demonstrate this is with a chair
obviously so if I want to lift this
chair
then I might hold it here see near to
the center of gravity that's relatively
easy but now if I move the grip to here
suddenly it becomes a lot more difficult
because now the center of gravity is
further away from the point of contact
if you want to find the progressions the
easiest way to do that is to look online
and just search for planche progressions
or Maltese progressions or front lever
progressions and then you'll see a list
of moves you can use and then you just
start with the easiest one and like I
say once you've mastered that move on to
the next one aiming for about a minute
hold another option for getting some of
these calisthenics moves is something
called Supra maximal training well that
basically means is that you're finding a
way to perform a move that you can't
normally normally by cheating in some
way with some kind of assist say for
instance you might place your feet too
lightly on a surface such as a chair and
performing plant or you might use a
little bit of momentum swing yourself up
into the plant position on parallel bars
and then lower yourself again so these
exercises are incredibly technical
they're very hard on the central nervous
system so should treat them like we
would treat compound lifts in the gym
they go at the start of the session and
then we follow them up with easier
exercises in this case that might mean
the easier progressions at the same time
you can use all of that regular
calisthenics work explosive movements
like the muscle up or like clapping
press ups in order to build explosive
starting strength as well as regular
movements like press ups and press up
variations such as Archer push-ups for
instance dips of ring dips so the way
that you use these bodyweight exercises
the way you create the mechanical drop
set is to start with a difficult move
and then drop down to a slightly easier
move the targets the exact same muscles
so for instance you might perform as
many dips as you can do then you might
perform as many assisted dips as you can
do then you might do press ups and then
you might do knee press ups so by doing
this you're doing all movements that
target to the pecs and the triceps but
you're allowing yourself to go pass
failure thereby building up a lot of
metabolic stress and muscle damage just
as you can do as a body builder with
weights this is what I think is missing
a lot of basic body weights training
programs designed for building muscle
size that strength is intensity I think
that if we're trying to build a
Nightwing program then breaking these up
into a push day and a pull day so one
day of push movements one day of
pull-ups and things like that makes a
lot of sense because it allows us to be
more intense on that one body part while
at the same time treating our body in a
compound holistic way rather than just
isolating specific muscle groups like
the bicep and don't assume that there's
no value to doing bent arm movements
things like the bent arm planche things
like planche presses these are all
really great ways to train your pecs and
generally the stronger you get in
calisthenics and the greater your
control over your body the easier going
to find making difficult workouts
because you've got more moves in your
repertoire more difficult moves but find
it easier to give yourself a great
workout wherever you are without
equipment other great moves you can
incorporate into a bodyweight training
day include rope climbs rope climbs are
fantastic for building bicep strength as
I've talked about before there are
concentric only form of exercise so they
don't cause much muscle fatigue and
their blimp grip you'll build fantastic
grip by doing rope climbs another great
thing to incorporate is rock climbing or
bouldering if you have a rock climbing
wall near you use it is fantastic for
your strengths roit ratio makes you
really explosive and dynamic at the same
time it's really great for muscle
endurance cause you'll be holding
yourself in position wasn't you look for
that next crag to grab brilliant for
building grip strength it's just all
round the perfect addition to a
calisthenics workout in general there's
lots of different equipment that you
should invest in if you want to have a
proper calisthenics workout at home I
made a video in the past on building a
home gym for calisthenics but just to go
over a few of the basics once again
parallel bars a plinth for dips for
things like handstand press ups for
things like things like v6l sits at the
same time you have power let's a low to
the ground there perhaps even better for
things like planche they're also smaller
and easier to transport they're also
very cheap all these things are very
cheap a pull-up bar of course is
essential for pulling movements and then
I do recommend getting a rope as I've
talked about in the past gymnastic rings
are fantastic purchase whenever you
perform a push up on gymnastics rings
you need to stabilize yourself using
lots of supportive muscles and this
builds a lot of strength as well as a
lot of proprioceptive body control
they're also really cheap and I highly
recommend getting gymnastics for
english'
more versatile over something like TRX
which costs the earth and doesn't do
anything that gymnastics wings can't
finally on top of all that also going to
incorporate a little bit of
weightlifting because our boy deke he
does often use big weights you saving a
lot of comics throwing around barbells
it makes a lot of sense for us to
combine our straight arm work and are
pulling work with things like rows with
things like military press as we talked
about in the past need to use 90 percent
of your one rep max in order to really
recruit the fastest twitch muscle fibers
and build pure power however we're gonna
go a little bit lighter because we're
using it in conjunction with
calisthenics and difficult progressions
and so we're going to do that just after
with a slightly lighter weight we're
gonna pump it out for eight to ten reps
alternatively you can use much higher
weights and put them at the start of
your workout and alternate between that
and your progressions depends on how you
want to progress
finally it's really important to build
your grip strength this is another key
component of gymnastic strength training
and calisthenics and something that
often goes overlooked basically your
grip is what connects you to the bar to
the ground and it's one of the most
important links in the whole chain if
you have a weak grip you won't be able
to perform something like hangs you
won't be able to perform something like
planche or more T's because too much
energy is gonna be involved in trying to
hold on to the bar or the floor even
with something like a handstand you're
going to be gripping the ground with
your fingers and that actually makes a
big difference to how well you can
balance and to the amount of energy you
exert whilst you're up there likewise if
you're struggling to balance with the
handstand press particularly be straight
arm hands down press which is very
challenging
then try putting the weight more on to
this part of the hand rather than the
heel and you'll find that it's a little
bit easier not to topple over and really
grip into the ground at the same time
again this is an example of how
something isn't obviously a grip related
exercise actually involves the hands and
the grip more than you might think I
made a whole video on grip strength
training as I always tend to say so
check that out if you want more on that
to build our grip we can use the rope
climbs that we're already using hands
are really good also for mobility so
just hang from the bar for as long as
you can but at the same time you can
also supplement this with light weights
different since wrist curls and pronated
wrist curls and at the same time
overcoming isometric does that means
squeezing a grip trainer when he's
trying to bend an iron bar something
where you're exerting maximum
force against something that doesn't
want to move when you do this you would
crew all of your muscle fibers at once
and this is one of the only
opportunities we have to attempt to warm
rep max with our grip training so it's
something I really recommend you do
incorporate into this kind of routine if
you do parkour you'll notice a big
difference the next time you do a
wall-mount once you've trained your grip
be able to hold on tight makes a huge
difference and to demonstrate how
important this is in gymnastics when you
grab onto the Rings you might want to
use something called a false grip this
means that your wrist is going to be at
the same height as the bar or the ring
and by doing that you make it easier to
transition smoothly into a muscle up
without needing momentum so it makes a
huge difference and that's essentially a
wrist curl so build that forearm
strength and build that grip strength
will make a huge difference to your
agility in your bility to move so to
summarize we're going to be focusing on
progressions and straight arm strength
and building toward some really cool
gymnastics move we're gonna start our
training routine with those from there
we're going to add in some lighter
compound lifts and weights then from
there we're gonna be using rope climbs
and mechanical drop sets and circuits in
order to train our bodies for muscle
size strength using regular calisthenics
and various different variations
explosive movements slower movements
slow eccentrics etc all of that is going
to be in the Nightwing training program
of course over at the website you can
find a full push day where I incorporate
some of these progressions as well as
other exercises you can use in order to
stimulate hypertrophy muscle endurance
etc and there's a little bit more extra
over at the patreon as well as there
will be for all these videos in this
series so head over there if you want
the full scoop so I hope you found this
video useful interesting guys who did
then please leave a like share around
comment down below and let me know if I
missed anything what you would add to a
Nightwing training program like I say
next time I return to this topic I'll be
talking about the core strength and her
mobility but I've got a lot of other
things on to cover in the meantime
starting with assassin training and
programming so if that sounds good then
please subscribe and I'll see you next
time thanks a ton for watching and bye
for now
you